meanwhile as the cascade of bad
headlines is just swamping the the
democrats right now
the
the biden administration is struggling
for a narrative the narrative that they
are now coming up with is that they have
defeated covet yes yes it was them they
did it it was the mandatory vaccine
mandate sure it was it was that
so yesterday joe biden wandered out to a
microphone and he spoke for a grand
total of seven minutes and then he
turned around and then he left
okay so
i mean that's all he can be expected to
do like he shows up every day he talks
for like 37 seconds and then he sort of
collapses out of the room and it's
dragged back to his casket where they
where they
perform some sort of
resuscitatory action upon him
and then uh he breathes lightly until
the next day when they pull him out of
the casket again and wheel him out so
president biden yesterday he came out
and he said our plan is working
oh interesting okay explain mr president
i want to provide a brief update on my
plan
that announced in early september to
accelerate the path out of this pandemic
it's working we're making progress
nationally
daily cases are down 47
hospitalizations are down 38 over the
past six weeks
over the past two weeks
most of the country has improved as well
case rates are declining in 39 states
and hospital rates are declining in 38
states okay let me point out how stupid
this is okay the reason that this is
unbelievably stupid
is because there are several reasons
reason number one the states that have
seen the largest scale declines are
states that have completely ignored joe
biden
florida never had vaccine mandates in
fact rhonda sanchez has been fighting
vaccine mandates pretty much every step
of the way and has vaccination rates
that are about the same as the
vaccination rates in california for
example they're not wildly different
hey joe biden is suggesting that it is
him yelling about vaccines that has
caused the pandemic to wane that old man
shouting at clouds made the pandemic
wayne nope
all that happened is that the pandemic
hits populations we spend lots of times
indoors
and then it wanes because it passes
through the population this is what
pandemics do
but this is joe biden's tried and true
method right there's a parade already
moving he jumps out in front of it and
claims credit for the parade
he did this with the vaccine roll out
itself he didn't have one iota to do
with the development of the vaccine his
vaccine rollout plan was the same as
trump's and then he jumped in front of
the parade and he was like well here i
am
and i look at yeah i did it it was me
success
and now he's doing the exact same thing
so the pandemic waned mostly in red
states where it had spiked and he's like
look what i did and jill look at me i'm
great at that
[Music]
amazing i'm amazing how he jumps in
this is constantly the policy of bad
bureaucrats
is that the problem already starts to
solve itself and then they jump in front
of it and they go oh it was me i did it
okay so according to joe biden joe biden
solved the pandemic by yelling at clouds
in reality his plan has not worked it is
also worthy of noting at this point that
all the vaccine mandates that he
supposedly used in order to get the
vaccine rates up the only one that has
actually been implemented to this point
is the federal contractor mandate there
is still no rule from it's been like
almost two months now there is still no
rule from osha that actually mandates
that employers over 100 employees
have to have to backs their people
so to credit his vaccine mandate with
the uptick in vaccination rates is a
stretch in and of itself
it is quite possible that one of the
reasons you saw an uptick in vaccination
rates is specifically because people
looked at the delta variant they said
okay i now have a choice i can either
get delta or not get delta i prefer not
to get delta i prefer to get the vaccine
and then if i get a breakthrough case
it'll be mild but again joe biden's
gonna claim credit for everything now
what's amazing about joe biden and our
current authoritarians
is that they truly believe that you are
bad you are divisive because you refuse
their their authoritarian mandate this
is an incredible statement from joe
biden what we're about to play so joe
biden is talking about divisiveness
now joe biden came into office on the
pledge that he was going to unify he
instead has proposed an agenda that
looks very much like bernie sanders
economic agenda and he's proposed a
covet agenda that is full top down
authoritarian in many ways
so he has completely run beyond his own
political mandate so joe biden came into
office with a political mandate it was
to be dead right not alive not trump
and moderate
two of those three he has fulfilled he
is dead he is not trump but he is
certainly not moderate
and yet according to joe biden it is it
is you
you who are dividing the country you you
won't listen to him and you won't do
what he wants you're dividing the
country now i noted this literally the
day of his inauguration in his speech he
kept talking about unity and i said well
there are two types of unity there's
unity in the sense that we'll leave you
alone and then we'll try to find some
higher purpose we can all pursue
together
but it's mostly gonna be us leaving you
alone right unity requires us to go
weapons down or unity could be you do
exactly what i want at points of gun in
now we're unified aren't we it's pretty
obvious which way joe biden has moved so
yesterday here he was saying that
vaccine mandates should not divide us i
have an idea don't do them then
let's be clear
vaccination requirements should not be
another issue that divides us
that's why
we continue to battle the misinformation
that's out there
and companies and communities are
setting up their
stepping up as well to
combat these
the misinformation
southwest airlines
at the head of the pilot the head of the
pilots union and the ceo dismiss critics
who claim
vaccination mandates contributed to
flight disruptions well who are you
going to believe joe biden about the
vaccine mandates contributing to flight
disruptions or your own lying eyes which
demonstrate that there was really no
other problem in the united states and
southwest was the only airline that had
been significantly affected
who are you going to believe about that
or the southwest employees we've been
talking to here at daily wire who are
explaining exactly why people are
sticking out
okay so
there is such an authoritarian streak in
this guy he mandates that you do a thing
if you don't do the thing you're being
divisive
if you refuse to acquiesce to his
demands you are the divisive one you're
a very divisive person for not doing
exactly what joe biden is telling you to
do that's an unbelievably authoritarian
and tyrannical statement
can then join just campers away when i
say scampers i mean he walks very slowly
away because he's not capable of
scampering anymore those legs ain't
gonna do it so here's joe biden just
walking away after seven minutes in the
glare of the public spotlight
thank you very much
[Applause]
and then joe biden kind of he kind of
fades away
joe biden
old presidents don't die they just walk
away
there's there's that president of the
united states just sort of he came out
for a moment and then he went back down
into his hole which means i believe
six more weeks of winter
okay so here's the thing it is pretty
obvious that whatever surge we had and
waning we had had nothing to do with joe
biden
according to the new york times after a
brutal summer surge driven by the highly
contagious delta variant the coronavirus
is again in retreat the united states is
recording roughly 90 000 new infections
a day down more than 40 since august
hospitalizations and deaths are falling
too
the crisis is not over everywhere the
situation in alaska is particularly dire
but nationally the trend is clear and
hopes are rising that the worst is
finally behind us again over the past
two years the pandemic has crashed over
the country in waves inundating
hospitals and then receding only to
return after americans let their guard
down i love how the new york times puts
that so it's that americans let their
guard down that causes the pandemic to
spike except that it's spiking in blue
areas too it is all about are you in
proximity to other people when it's cold
outside people go inside and then they
get infected when it's really hot
get infected
okay that's all
and this baseline notion that if you get
infected it's because you have been
sinful in some way is ridiculous a lot
of the people who are getting infected
are people who got vast they're just
getting breakthroughs
the new york times says it's difficult
to tease apart the reasons the virus
ebbs and flows in this way and harder
still to predict the future
uh no it's actually not all that
difficult to explain i just did it in
two sentences as winter looms there are
real reasons for optimism nearly 70
percent of adults are fully vaccinated
many children under 12 are likely to be
eligible for their shots in a matter of
weeks federal regulators could soon
authorize the first anti-viral pill for
covet at 19. by the way joe biden said
yesterday that parents are going to
sleep more solidly at night knowing that
their children won't be in danger
because of the vaccine
those of us who've been watching the
stats have been sleeping solidly at
night about our kids for long i wasn't
sleeping solidly about my parents my
parents are 65. i've been sleeping very
solidly about my seven five and
one-year-old because kids aren't dying
of this in anything remotely like
significant numbers
if that is not morally significant
numbers every every kid who dies is a
morally significant life but if you're
talking about statistical significance
the grand total number of kids who have
died in the united states from covid 19
without serious pre-existing conditions
according to dr martin mccary of johns
hopkins university is currently between
10 and 20.
now 10 and 20 000
hey that is not the kind of thing that
keeps me awake at night
i am not kept awake at night by the fact
that 10 to that my child
is in significant danger if 10 to 20
kids across a country of 330
million people have died of covert
without pre-existing conditions
okay but again you must be you must be
cudgelled
into into
the belief that these people have solved
the problem as opposed to you know the
virus just doing what the virus does
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed